welcome to your mom's house
we had killer Thai massages Friday Tom
hates couples massages have we talked
about this on the show I don't think we
brought it up yeah oh where the lady one
time goes when two couples massage Tom
what god no God it sounds fucking Tara
when I was like relax and so you made a
big thing of it yeah well yeah it's a
little embarrassing when you hear my
husband were supposed to do stuff
together we did do stuff together so
they didn't want to put us together
because then you go oh is she gonna be
able to walk on my back yeah
and they're like oh no not if you said
that same womb it's been there to give
us separate rooms
did they say I don't remember you just
said that I remember but you just said
it
no no because I said she's gonna walk on
my back and you know and they said not
not in the same room sir so then they
put you in another room and did she walk
on your back yeah yeah yeah it's good my
lady wait about 250 babe she listens to
the show
maybe there's no way she there's no way
she and she jumped up on my back and I
had that moment of like oh fuck she's
250 at least yeah I thought she was
gonna break me for sure so I had to be
like oh I just had a baby three months
ago take it easy on me instead of you're
too fat to be sitting on top of me cuz
what do you do what she's a big bitch
then she oh I so sorry and she backed up
you like that yeah but what do you do if
she's a big old bitch I like it you do
yeah I'm the heavier the better actually
seriously really yeah cause it feels--oh
but you said she was too hard on you
this time yes and she was not big that's
that I could not believe it she was tiny
and I was like oh like my eyes were
watering I was like Jesus but she also
was doing things that didn't really like
there's certain parts of like you know
your shin yeah or your outer like the
quad I forget the the
there where it's sensitive almost I
think on everyone and she was going full
pressure I go ha ha she goes ha ha and I
always laugh when you hurt I was like ah
she's like take it easy there ok
my favorite they stretch you and it's
always too much it's always too much of
a stretch yeah my inner thigh meat is
real delicate and she's got mash yeah I
was like dude sometimes the stretches
are too aggressive that's what I'm yeah
yeah dude I was facedown takes my leg up
like bend at the knee and then
immediately push it to my butt where I
was like maybe ease into that kind of
steps I know I don't like when they
crack anything on meat you haven't
wrapped I like I like that but I don't
trust the neck crack used to live on the
east side we used to go to the same
place like every time yeah there's a
girl who would go like take your neck
well cuz these motherfuckers are not
chiropractic no qualified and they would
just like whisk her off to another
massage place they'd be like Cathy kill
somebody make her go to to sunrise
massage because you can't work here no
more
yeah well this place was nice because
you noted that it didn't smell like
their stinky food sometimes with would
tie it'll just like a restaurant yeah
cuz they'll all bring in their
Tupperware your stuff and it stinks like
a fucking restaurant you know it's
always real spicy too you tell that's
gonna give you wring snake yeah
sometimes I smell their breath like you
it when they could you face up and then
right close garlic breath
one thing I don't like to hear is when
it when the massage takes too much out
of us and you hear them breathe and
they're like like dude I'm not gonna
relax with you hyperventilating yeah
that's true but that Thai massage is
always a great because it's dirt cheap
it's so cheap that's the whole thing you
can you feel you can do it all the time
it's so cheap yeah
one time I went to a resort it was my
dad had a business trip and I went there
and I did like it was like a five-star
resort they had a spa and I go I go get
a massage I call it a thing to specify
things they gave me an old man no yes
and during the massage he was like like
every pressure thing it sound like it
was his last breath every single time
Footwear is just listen to the whole
time was this guy breathing this is my
last massage it was it was rough man I
used to go to this guy this one guy in
Silver Lake oh yeah we heard a lot about
him yeah he's great
apparently though he was touching the
tits cuz I sent him I sent other girls
to him and he was touching their tits
nice I'm saying you shouldn't do that
but nice he never touched my tits sure I
played some great discs include that I
could you'll trip over I give you a tip
massage now babe what if though series
that's going in of course that's
terrible could be but apparently he was
feeling up all the other people he never
filmed me up maybe you wanted a little
bit too my friends they said that he
felt that his home
so did you they said that they felt that
much yes the day when he when you go on
your back that he was giving them titty
massage I don't think so
this guy was a little effeminate he
wasn't you know he never did it to you
no not once
why do you think he did not because I've
got huge slobbers why would you not want
to feel those maybe you didn't know
where they began where they
did or something I don't know okay no
because I don't I don't know I don't
know why maybe he saw you coming with me
a few times and he knew like this bitch
has a bear he's home got a big bear with
you